okay let's go ahead and get started
welcome everyone to our Thursday
informatics research conference and it
gives me great pleasure to introduce an
old friend of mine although I know like
calling things old just like when I
introduced Tom Paine a couple weeks ago
and said he was an old friend of mine
but anyways dr. Bowen dr. Judy bone and
I have known each other for a long time
we both come from internal medicine
backgrounds in fact you probably were
when I was still seeing patients in the
division of general medicine we're
probably my boss for some period of time
or at least for that part of my job but
anyways we've both moved on and Judy has
she's working on a PhD in medical
education and is involved in a lot of
medical education activities here and I
think this talk came about because
Vishnu was talking to her about some of
the issues around following up in the
patient record as a learning experience
you know which actually raises a lot of
issues but I'll let her talk about that
so dr. Bowen has appointments in both
the School of Medicine and nursing she
did her undergraduate degree in
biochemistry at Williams College and
then received her MD from Dartmouth
Medical School she completed a an
internship in pediatrics at the
University of Utah and then pursued a
residency in internal medicine at
Virginia Mason Medical Center so just a
few logistical reminders we're not using
the microphone buttons anymore we're
using this thing and so Lynne will run
around the room and and the main reason
for using the microphone is so people
listening because we stream this can
listen in
and also because we record these things
and so it gets captured that way and for
those who are listening in as always if
you have questions you can send them by
Twitter make sure that you put the
hashtag D mice comp DM IC e conf that
hashtag and we'll try to get those asked
to the speaker so I will turn it over to
Judy bill thanks very much it does take
me back I think we both earned our gray
hair proudly Vishnu thanks for the
conversation and the invitation and I'm
delighted to be here hello to all of you
who I are out there somewhere in
cyberspace what I'm going to do today is
to share with you some of my research
that led to some pretty interesting
questions for me about how clinicians
are using the electronic health record
to accomplish some of their learning
goals and I look forward to the
conversation that I hope I've left
plenty of time for us to have to see if
there are ways in which we can tackle
some of some of the findings so without
further ado we'll get going
so I have nothing to disclose educators
generally in this country generally
don't have anything to disclose I have
several learning outcomes for each of
you and I framed them as an educator as
at the end of this presentation what I
think you will be able to do so my
teaching job is to get you to that place
there are multiple choice questions
posted if you want continuing education
credit for this conference you need to
complete the multiple-choice test but
there's an alternative way of thinking
about those MCQs which is if you take
them and Lin provides the aggregate
response back to me not your individual
but the sum total it helps me as an
educator decide whether or not my
presentation has been effective so
please feel free to complete the
multiple-choice test that will be posted
online I am hoping that you will be able
to describe discontinuities in the
health system that require physicians to
transfer or transition responsibility
for patient care
and by transitioning responsibility I
mean physicians have temporary
responsibilities and someone else takes
over I don't mean the night team covers
and I come back the next day we're
really talking about information
discontinuity and responsibility that
ends and what positions do at the end of
that responsibility you will be able to
identify factors that motivate
physicians to pursue follow-up when
they're no longer responsible for their
patients and hopefully you'll be able to
compare and contrast tracking features
of two different electronic health
system records for pursuit for carrying
out that follow-up and describe
opportunities to improve information
management for learning well that's
where we're headed
let me give you some background
physicians routinely transition
responsibility for patient care to other
physicians our health system is full of
discontinuities research on transitions
and handovers has primarily focused on
patient safety but not learning there's
a lot of literature out there worried
about the quality of our handovers and
whether or not patients are safe in the
process of those handovers so I became
interested in this as an educator what
about learning these transitions of care
interrupt clinical reasoning if I'm
taking care of a patient and I propose a
diagnostic hypothesis and the patient
over before the diagnosis is known I
have a lost opportunity to learn from
the consequences of that clinical
reasoning and decision-making and
without knowing the theory would suggest
that I hang on to my process because I'm
not reasoning to get it wrong I'm
reasoning to get it right and in the
absence of feedback I'm likely to use
the same reasoning strategy the next
time for a similar case follow-up about
patient care usually occurs through the
electronic health record and that's
where our worlds intersect so today's
focus is on information discs on
what are the health system drivers of
discipline of information discontinuity
so one of them is duty hours and I that
this is in fact what first got me
interested in this topic I was
absolutely certain that institutions who
responded to restricting residents hours
for working primarily responded to that
to that requirement by increasing shift
work and night float rotations and I
thought for sure that we were training
training shift learners but I'm going to
ask you now so that you can be actively
engaged in this presentation to give me
some other thoughts about what you think
that information discontinuities are but
let me let me ask first for a show of
hands how many and you can do this out
there in cyberspace as well how many of
you are clinicians and have experience
with these kinds of transitions good so
it more than half of you in the room
know what I'm talking about
what other experiences do you have with
information discontinuity besides
potentially the shift work that we've
created to address do the opposite yes
division of labor excellent what else
exactly so transitions right yep thanks
Bill
so transitions in care locations
essentially we transition patients from
inpatient settings to outpatient
settings sometimes those are connected
in the electronic health record as they
are at OHSU through epic but often they
are not what else yes tell us more about
how that shows up as an information
discontinuity
okay so consultation the roles that we
have which is also a division of labor
between specialists and generalists or
specialists and hospitalists regardless
of whether it's adult or pediatric
medicine often is left with poor
communication between those two
individuals whether it's through the
electronic health record okay great so
let me show you my list it turns out
that we structure residents work in
blocks so they finish a block rotation
and they sign over their list so it's
also fundamentally how we structure work
turns out that hospitalist work has been
structured in blocks from the beginning
of the hospice movement and there's some
movement within that should it be a
month should be two weeks are these
seven on seven off five on weekends five
off it varies in the different systems
but each one of those creates a
discontinuity of information at the end
at that transition point we talked about
division of labor I'm characterizing
that as specialized care units it used
to be that we had less sub
specialization and internist spec and
our day bill you and I trained and we
took care of patients in and out of the
intensive care unit because we didn't
have specialized intensivist now that's
a specialized unit there are specialized
cardiology units and that requires even
within the same Hospital a transition of
responsibility and then we don't keep
patients in the hospital very long again
back in our day we spent less time
worrying about length of stay and we got
to see the whole case unfold now we
transition from inpatient to outpatient
and if that's across a record system so
that you can't act necessarily know what
happens it requires a conversation with
the outpatient physician and in
so those transitions between health care
systems there's lots of discontinuity
opportunity so what happens well it
turns out my study was qualitative and
I'm going to share with you snippets of
the data set that when I asked my study
participants how these two where they
experienced discontinuity one of my
study participants said these
transitions between systems are
significantly problematic this is
especially true for cases were most
likely to be interested in the really
difficult cases that are transferred in
from an outside Hospital for diagnostic
evaluation they may or may not get the
right records or have access to that and
then when the patients discharge back
there's a loss of opportunity to
follow-up so the purpose of my research
is to explore the phenomenon of
physicians follow-up activities and
choices after transitioning
responsibility for patient care to other
physicians at any one of these
discontinuity points I used how many of
you have done qualitative methods all
right so it won't hurt to review this a
little bit
I took a construct constructivist
grounded Theory approach which basically
means I didn't come in with an AA priori
hypothesis about what I would find and
in fact I was quite surprised that the
focus was not on shift work I conducted
this research at this single academic
Medical Center with people working in
the hospital because of the known
frequent transitions of responsibility
that occur in hospitals and I conducted
individualized semi-structured
interviews instead of focus groups
because I was really interested in in
exploring some of the emotional
reactions to finding out what happened
to patients and I wasn't sure that I
would be able to get at that kind of
exposure if the stories were told in
front of the colleagues they were all
internal mental medicine hospitalists
and residents and they were all
face-to-face interviews I used a
critical incident method and I won't go
into that any more in detail other than
to say it's
often used to explore or trigger recall
of exemplary or problematic events and
then trying to unpack and understand
what that's about so ahead of the
interview I sent these prompts to my
participants think about a time when you
work through a diagnostically
challenging clinical case that it was
your responsibility and that others had
not yet figured out after your
responsibility for this case ended and
you handed it over to others you learned
that the final diagnosis was the same as
the one that you originally thought it
might be and then the second prompt was
identical except I said and was
different from what you originally
thought it might be the prompts were
provided 24 hours in advance because I
wanted that trigger recall to occur
outside of the interview so we could
spend the time in the interview
exploring what they recalled but you
need to keep in mind a limitation of
this method is that these responses were
retelling of historical events it wasn't
that I was interviewing them immediately
after following up on a particular case
and getting immediate responses and we
remember the stories accurately but we
remember them differently often from the
way that they originally were so there's
some limitation to that I used a
constant comparison method where we did
coding as we were bringing in the
interviews and as we were discovering
what we were finding it allowed us to
modify the interview guide to explore
things that we hadn't anticipated we
used open coding initially to get the
codebook that was stable enough to apply
to all of the transcripts and then we
used axial and selective coding for
interpretation and further exploration
of qualitative analytic methods is
probably time for another conversation
the sensitizing concept was motivation
we did not go in and say we're looking
for motivation but we were interested
generally in whether or not physicians
followed up because part of my are
priori believed was we were training
shift workers and that our physicians
would say was my responsibility anymore
so I don't do that anymore so we went in
with some understanding that if they
were following up it might be related to
motivation our data was set was judged
which is different from saturation it's
a new terminology sufficient because the
last two interviews really provided no
new information so we stopped and
settled for the data set that we've had
reflectivity and qualitative research
basically means that because I'm a
general internist and I've worked in the
hospital I have close knowledge of the
experience of my participants I had been
a resident in that before and that I was
likely to have some blind spots about
what it is that I was seeing so I
invited Co investigators who didn't have
that perspective to keep me honest about
my interpretations we had 18
participants seven of 11 of them were
hospitalists with a range of less than a
year to more than 11 years of experience
and seven internal medicine residents
upon across the three years of training
let me share with you the results in
relationship to motivation to set us up
for how did they pursue that which gets
us to the informatics conversation so
care represented by the white arrow is
transitioned at the at those points of
the end of responsibility and our
participants almost uniform and used the
word I followed up when I was curious so
that was our first point of division in
the data set when there was sufficient
curiosity they pursued follow-up when
there was insufficient curiosity they
generally had to make a choice not to
follow up choices were related to time I
feel like it takes time but it refines
me as a diagnostician and as a person I
find this time really well spent
again for the ones where there was
reason or motivation to follow up there
was insufficient curiosity predictably
across the set of interviews when
patients were viewed to have problems
that the clinician
felt was straightforward patients who
come in with something relatively
straightforward and clinically
clinically I'm usually something like
urinary tract infection pneumonia or
maybe congestive heart failure all of
that dependent on years of experience
things that seem clear straightforward
they get treated they feel better they
go home and I know they have good
follow-up
there were no loose ends those patients
didn't make the list there were three
reasons why our study participants were
curious to follow up and the follow-up
was all voluntary in our system we had
no requirements for following up and
their goals for following up was to
sleep seek closure on the loose ends or
the uncertainty the first and largest
domain was clinical uncertainty I was
curious if my assessment was correct if
I predicted the course which I didn't it
was a learning moment so curiosity
really drives me I think that's the
underlying trigger and then it leads to
more reflection a learning objective
that I could use in the future it
provides a little closure the second
reason was something we didn't
anticipate which was personal attachment
sometimes I have a personal connection
with a patient I like them and I just
want to want to sort of check in I have
this personal investment a relationship
that we had over a brief period of time
it's sort of amazing how you can develop
this very intense relationship with a
person you've only known for three to
four days in the hospital and on some
level I'm just curious there isn't
necessarily just clinical curiosity but
personal curiosity often times those two
things ran together and then
interestingly there was this notion of
patient Vollmer ability because of the
socio-economic issues at play
sketchy discharges are often not the
ones I particularly bonded with to be
quite honest with you the person with
substance abuse and a personality
disorder is also the person with the
highest risk discharge when I get into
the chart is there something I can do to
help either this patient or a patient in
the future so what really came out was
the sense of advocacy and support for
patients they felt to be at highest risk
so goals of seeking closure felt into
two categories clinical curiosity to
secure the diagnosis and understand the
disease process and build knowledge and
relational curiosity to know the
palliative patients ferret and to
advocate for going
so how did they do this tracking
information is a management challenge to
a person almost they all said oh yeah I
charge stock which was also a surprise
to me during the time that I was doing
data collection I was invited to be a
visiting professor at the University of
Iowa and then the university UAB Alabama
and I in oftentime is for those of you
that have had that opportunity you get
to go out with the chief residents and
have breakfast ER dinner and the person
who invited me said so Judy tell him
what you're up to and I started to
describe my research and they said oh
you mean chart stalking so not only it
was a local word it was a regional to
national word this thing called charts
knocking so I'm using my prior figure
and I'm just starting with that box
about sufficient curiosity sufficient
curiosity meant I need I want to follow
up in the future so I have to make a
list I have to hang on to the patient so
I know that I can go back sometimes
those lists were on paper often those
lists were in the electronic health
record and we found that the electronic
health record was either easy to use or
difficult difficult the EHRs led to
workarounds and those workarounds were
either leaving chart notes open and
unsigned which drives of course health
records people with nuts but it always
shows up in your in basket if it's
unsigned which was a way of creating a
workaround list to say I've got some
things I want to keep following up so
I'm gonna ignore the requirement to sign
my note within 48 hours or 24 hours they
often left unsigned discharge summaries
as well or they went back to keeping
paperless but every person that said I
keep paperless had some concerns about
whether that those lists would be lost
and then lose opportunity to follow up
and that too protected health
information concerns so for example the
time it takes to track patients I
actually worry about less than the fact
that I'm technically violating hospital
by keeping cards we've been discouraged
from keeping any sort of record which i
think is the detriment so that's one
thing that worries me someone will
eventually find my stack of paper in my
office and I'll be in trouble about that
so we saw some people abandoning the
tracking activity for learning purposes
entirely because they're concerned about
being caught or having been caught led
to abandoning the activity or breaching
the rules because the priority for being
able to follow up exceeded being
compliant with rules what are the
features of the electronic health record
that was easy to use they had tracking
features that were embedded within the
electronic health record they could drag
and drop patient names and numbers into
a personal list that only they could see
which made it really easy to find those
patients and then they were hyperlinked
so they could just click on that and get
right into the record they also have
annotation capabilities where they could
apply a sticky note to say this is why I
wanted to look because if I now have 20
patients on my list and it happened over
the last 72 hours I might have forgotten
and I have to then recapture why I
needed to look for example I just
clicked the patient's name and then
click right into the chart the sticky
notes served as a memory prompter they
each are equivalent of a journal now
difficult of sorry difficult electronic
health records didn't have these
features and they were described as
having separate computerized systems it
was okay you had permission to create an
electronic health list but it was in a
different record system that was related
but not connected to the electronic
health record and it required
transferring the patient's name and
number into this new list and it created
learning challenges for these
individuals
there was no capability for annotation
for example it's hard to find places to
write down patients names
in other words they had to go through a
paper writing staff to get it into the
other system apparently there's a way to
make a list but I can barely even log
into that system and get past the first
screen I have to get somebody to walk me
through how that system in the linked
how that system worked I can't give a
one-liner so sometimes I forget where
people are you can see that these
barriers made it much harder to do the
kind of charts talking in one hospital
as compared to the other and this is why
many of my participants kept cards so in
conclusion physicians were intrinsically
motivated to follow up when sufficiently
curious about unresolved issues because
of our analysis through motivation
theory which I'm not going to bore you
with today we have a word of caution
here these were intrinsically motivated
individuals if we make it a requirement
it shifts to extrinsic motivation and it
might actually under undermine the
activity so we have to be careful about
deciding based on my findings for other
reasons as well that we should just
immediately make it a requirement time
pressures led to trade-offs I might
learn something from every patient but I
have to choose participants sacrifice
personal time and they made choices
electronic health records facilitate or
inhibit longitudinal patient tracking
constraints led to workarounds or
abandonment and some strategies put
patient personal health information at
risk so where do we go with this
information I would propose that we need
to optimize electronic health record
tools for learning purposes not just
patient safety not just documentation
not just billing and we need to do it in
a way that eliminates the need for
clinicians to keep paperless and can
address these workarounds I would
propose that we need a curriculum to
address the training gap that where we
would teach physicians how to use the
tools that exist because even in the
record where we had good use of tools
and they were able to drag-and-drop
click and open and leave sticky notes
had attending hospitals physicians
learning from residents so it was a very
haphazard way in which they even knew
those tools existed so as the tools
evolve and address gaps we have to do
remember to do periodic training updates
and then I would also argue that we need
to address the ethical concerns we saw
physicians tracking patients for a very
long time in some circumstances what is
the reach of the patient's informed
consent for being able to access the
record there's been a lot of debate in
the medical literature about whether
medical students should have access to
records for learning purposes and in
some places they're restricted from
being able to open charts after their
responsibility has has ended and yet all
their role models are at least it
suggests from my research tracking so
how do we deal with that disconnect and
why would we assume that a medical
student might not have the capacity to
function in protecting health
information respecting confidentiality
but suddenly as you become a physician
in turn all of that is presumed and
residents and faculty are role models so
it creates a disconnect organ treatment
for the students I'd like to thank my
collaborators Bridget O'Brien
and David Irby are both non clinicians
with great ability to help me with my
reflectivity and their education
researchers at UCSF John iljin some of
you may know he did a master's of
clinical research here and was an
emergency medicine education fellow he's
now at the University of Washington and
all attend contests some of you may know
is education researcher from the
Netherlands and all of the participants
from the
medicine residents and hospitals here at
OHSU I'm happy to stop there and take
questions thank you
[Applause]
and I probably should say questions and
discussion because I'm hoping that I can
collaborate with somebody who's really
interested in where to go next
one experiences with my experience that
I wanted to add curious if you encounter
this too is during residency I noticed
that some attendings they would
encourage that and they would receive
this following up as an an expression of
taking ownership of a patient you do you
think that something that's like adding
like more external motivation
conflicting with
it's a great question some of my
participants talked about having great
role models who encouraged follow up one
of the hospitalist positions said this
is how I do my rounds we we set some
time aside everybody gets choice about
who they want to follow up and how they
want to follow up and the medical
students are included in that activity
for this particular hospitalist and the
and the hospitalist is very careful to
help the student pick a patient to
followup with especially if it requires
a phone call to find out how they're
doing that's likely to leave them with a
positive encounter so there's a
screening activity that occurs because
of the inside of this attending around
some of these some of these challenging
issues none of the participants talked
about any of that encouragement as being
a requirement so I think it's all in the
perception of whether you believe
someone is forcing you to do something
in your in your free time that you don't
want to be doing versus feeling is so
you have a choice I think we can explain
for example there's value in following
up its role modeled by our faculty and
our residents for other residents and
students and residents for faculty but
it's still left with some choice because
intrinsic motivation requires choice and
curiosity to be the drivers that it
comes from within edge all right I think
there's opportunity to explore a little
bit further how close can we get to
saying there's value in this it can be
in a part of a training program and
still honor some of that intrinsic
motivation
Thanks it's I knew a little bit about
your work but it's interesting to
explore it in more detail I'm actually
curious about this sort of patient
consent issue and if anyone because
there are UN the dr. ed email list
because this issue came up there and and
I had never thought about well you know
what is the patient think about this and
then have had a recently a similar issue
you know one of our research projects
here is looking at retrieving patient
records based on queries and because
we're evaluating a system that does that
we have people who are medically trained
going in and determining whether this
record should or should not have been
retrieved
oh but by the way there's the wrong
another patient's notes got in here or
what happens when people find an error
things like that it when you start to
think about it it makes you wonder about
some of these other issues that you know
because back in our day you know the
records were so inaccessible we never
really had the opportunity to follow up
but now it's relatively easy and so what
what are what is the thinking on some of
these issues about consent and and
particularly when issues in the
patient's care are identified and that
person is no longer involved in their
care what's published in the education
literature is slim the conversations
going on in in social media such as dr.
Edie are our gaining steam so I think
that that's an issue that we probably
ought to explore thoughtfully as
researchers there's a one camp that
basically says the patients are not
giving consent beyond much beyond the
episode of care for us to be going back
in and following what's happening
there's another camp that says if
follow-up helps us be better
diagnosticians better clinicians
even more compassionate or humanistic
positions in this relational follow-up
notion then we should probably inform
our patients that this is what happens
now and do they have objections I would
like to find a middle ground by saying
if we're going to change it we need
their proprietors that build electronic
health records we need interprofessional
clinician groups and we need patients to
say what are the drivers what should we
be doing and how do we create a learning
system that allows us to do this but I
would say I think there are probably
some limits I was a little shocked to
hear some of the stories from some of
the hospitalists that they just had
ongoing curiosity because the diagnosis
was extremely rare and they wanted to
keep checking months more sometimes more
than a year later the same what happened
to this patient if we step back from
that is it an ethical question or is it
a learning question and I think that's
not necessarily that have become an
externally driven black-and-white
decision I think learning ISM is a
perception of what that value is and I
think that's what makes it but I think
we can find a solution to that yeah
because then this is against the
backdrop of another issue that we talk
about increasingly in informatics which
is ownership of the data and people
envisioning in the future your data
won't be sitting inside epic it will be
sitting out in the cloud somewhere and
epic and and you as a patient will give
access to the appropriate people and
then epic will go fetch the data that it
needs and do all the things that it
needs to do with it and then put it back
in the cloud so I mean which is a
potential solution in the patient
because you'll have to keep track track
of who the patient is agreeing to let
see their data and the patient could be
said oh would you allow your previous
clinician to look at at your data for
follow-up I you know my eye
with these data fell on the side of you
should we do anything and then I started
asking a couple of patients don't you
think about this and they all said you
mean you care enough about me that you
would want to keep following to make
sure that I did okay so it may be again
in this conversation that you would need
to worry less about that I worry more
about people getting their hands on data
that that they shouldn't be getting
their hands on one thing and if if in
fact we're charting in the wrong chart
and the charts are open to patients that
patients are learning about other
patients and so we've really got to be
vigilant about how it is that we manage
they input into those charts as well as
the extraction but it shouldn't be a
one-sided conversation the patient
should be part of that but I rebuilt
that we might create be really rule
bound in all of that which will just get
us into a different problem of I can't
learn through following up we have a
discontinuous healthcare system I think
I've made that case we're not going to
go back we're not going to train
clinicians to just be 24/7 365 for a
cohort of patients it's not going to
happen
specialized care units all of these
things have actually improved the
quality of care so we have to fix it
through probably an electronic health
record so we have to be possible yes
Thanks great presentation this is likely
outside the scope of your project but as
a medical student often I've seen that
one of the learning uses of the EHR is
learning how to be a communicate
effective communicator medical students
will obviously like if they're working
on the patient's look back and see like
how the resident has presented the case
or ass more senior clinician and learn
in that realm and I'm wondering if you
have any thoughts about the value of
that and how you could direct students
I'm so glad you're here are there any
other medical students in the room so
you're carrying flag that's wonderful I
probably have more questions for you
than you have for me obviously our
learning goals for you around
communication are written communication
and verbal communication in multiple
directions right you need to be able to
create after visit summaries that
actually help patients to be successful
when they leave the supervision of your
care and Institute self care with your
guidance that's also a conversation
about clarifying and checking back do
they really understand that and I
believe strongly as an educator that we
do a lot of role modeling of written and
verbal communication and one of the ways
in which you will be able to pick and
choose who are your best role models for
that and how does it resonate for you as
you develop your identity as a physician
is to have multiple different examples
of the types of written communication
that you find helpful and you want to
copy the kites of written communication
that you don't find helpful that you
don't want a institutional or Institute
on your own front and the only way you
figure that out is to see both good and
bad examples on both ends and and how
people negotiate what kinds of things
ought to be documented in your chart in
a way that is responsible clear
respectful and empathic to patients
because our records are open data so how
we do that again it's very different
from the era that bill and I trained in
or we thought much less about it we are
hopefully before the end of the era of
paternalism but all you have to do is
listen to the conversations you see
going on to know that that's not
entirely true so if you're taking care
of me and I don't have the background
that I have how might I overreact to
what you write in a note is something
that is a challenge for us with
communication for words so the more
you're able to see how your role models
document and ongoing documentation
tracking I think it's really important
so I I'm leaning on the side of why have
we drawn a line around the students
access to that record implying that
maybe they're not yet adults enough to
be ethical about the protection of
patient health information personal
health information that suddenly changes
without any training for interns and
that maybe we need to rethink that
conversation but my question back to you
is have you been restricted from
tracking patients in the past and does
anybody in the room know what our
Hospital policy is about student
accessing charts into the future after
your responsibility for care is ended
if I've ever like wanted to track
someone it's always been possible
whether it's been easy as your talk is a
different issue and it's totally
dependent on the location the work and
whether or not you okay great
does anybody know what the policy is
here
exactly what were you told
okay
thank you I guess
so I was interested when you started and
talked about kind of the limitations and
the the discontinuity that happens when
we transition care and kind of handoff
our patients from one setting to another
I was wondering when you kind of talked
about how the follow-up or people's
motivation to follow up was either based
on the complexity of the case or their
attachment to the patient do you have
any insight on whether those same
factors influence the quality of that
handoff if someone felt like it was a
more interesting case or they were more
attached to their patient did they give
a better handoff where were their
handoffs more comprehensive or more
detailed as opposed to a patient that in
their mind was simple and
straightforward I'm just kind of curious
if that idea or the cognitive state of
the physician at the time the reason why
they wanted to follow up if that also
affected the the ways in which they
transition the care or transition their
patient to the next provider that is a
phenomenal question does the cognitive
state of curiosity unfinished clinical
questions attachment advocacy change the
nature of the way the handover occurs
you want to collaborate on that I don't
haven't read anything in the literature
that anyone's connected those dots all
of the handover literature is about
following a protocol that's supposed to
increase the safety and decrease
communication difficulties loose ends I
will tell you that I have several
examples in my dataset of residents
handing over their lists and the next
morning or later that same night going
back in and getting anxious because the
team they handed it off to was not
attending to the patient in the way that
they wanted to I had a faculty position
saying it drives me nuts to go in and
watch and see what's happened when I had
a relationship and attachment and a plan
with this patient and they didn't hear
me so I think there's probably something
to that but my research didn't explore
that question specifically and I think
it's
so chilly I had a comment on a question
the comment is really that the the
immediate value that I see from this is
the ability to start thinking about
transforming the electronic health
record into a teaching tool I think it
was the late Larry Reid who who wrote
that paper what 4050 years ago are
medical records that guide and teach
we've done a lot of guiding from medical
records since then but very little
teaching because the EHR has started
generating so much data that the
teaching value of that of that of that
tool has dropped dramatically in the
last couple of decades so my comment is
that is that perhaps this is an
opportunity for us to start thinking
about how to design the EHR interface to
better promote lifelong self learning in
a model by which you do something you
iteratively see an outcome because of it
and then you get better and better by
being able to do this again and again
and again in tiny little Alec watts my
question to you is is you talked a
little bit about the motivation of
people to actually go and chart stuff I
hope that none of the residents talked
about this but did they knew the
attendings actually consider legal
issues or medical liability as a reason
that they go back and review the chart
was that a theme that was it was was
touched upon if I compare if a
paraphrase your question to check to
make sure I'm answering the right
question did any of the charts talking
occur because the participant clinician
felt they were at medical legal risk and
they wanted to know how that was playing
out not explicitly there's one story
where a clinician said the reason this
case I'm telling you about is so
memorable is because I was peer reviewed
for it and that led then to part of my
questioning was what do you do
differently as a result of following up
which are not data that I'd shared with
you and this individual said now I over
order and I'm waiting to come back to
some sort of appropriate level of
testing but I have to go through this
period of over testing because I was
peer reviewed so there was one example
of that because of them.this but nobody
talked about being motivated because
they they felt that they were vulnerable
you have to remember that this is
historical retelling of their chosen
stories and those chosen stories were
prompted by was did the team receiving
the patient she keep your diet
provisional diagnosis or change it and
and I'll share with you because of the
question that I very deliberately asked
about changed diagnoses because I didn't
want to imply that a change diagnosis is
an error I will tell you that a hundred
percent said oh you mean when I made a
mistake or some other response to that
there's something about internists
perhaps maybe physicians at large that
not getting the provisional diagnosis
right me isn't translated as a medical
error or a mistake in some cases it was
very clear that it was an error of
omission or omission they could see what
they had done and they said I'll
remember this case forever because it
helped me to see that blind spot but
there were other cases where they felt
like they've made a mistake but in fact
it was a diagnosis in evolution and when
I tried to explore that with them they
still said but I'm supposed to get it
right so there's something about our
training culture in the internal
medicine maybe more broadly that says
our job is to get it right and so I
think that's a whole nother talk and
other directions for my particular
research which is how do we start to
consider the diagnostic process as a
social process among team members across
these discontinuities in a way that
actually allows us to talk about them
learn and learn together from them
rather than a signing play because there
was a lot of self play a lot of what we
talked about our discussed has been of
all around the motivation primarily for
communication effectively and
dissemination and distribution of
information within what appears to be
largely I like to let me use the word
social because that's actually kind of
art going with this distributed social
system yeah so have you given any
thought or consideration to studies that
have looked at motivation in medical
learning as a function of the social
network itself and so looking at the
relationship between the residents or
between people coming into for example a
nursing program and examining how that
network shifts and whether properties of
that network may be responsible for how
information is disseminated or may drive
ways that information is disseminated so
social network analysis is a as a tool
and a strategy for looking at how it is
that relationships consolidate and shift
among communities in shared activities
if I'm if I'm paraphrasing sort of this
notion so and I yeah right so but so the
part of the other part of the data set
that I haven't shared with you is when
the third prompt was you're on the
receiving end and you change someone
else's diagnosis and those stories were
filled with
reticence about telling the other person
that we changed the diagnosis so it gets
to your question of communication
difficulties and so we looked carefully
at the circumstances where the response
to the interview prompt was of course I
did that's how we work but those were in
pocket
and so we're we're still doing that
analysis but the pockets seem to be
related to characteristics of
communities of trust and relationship
that are embedded in longitude analogies
and so I think it gets to your question
and and that's what's and that's what's
coming next
couldn't agree with you more it also
turns out that that physical parks
proximity matters that the for example a
group of residents that have stayed
together on a team or in a firm and
develop relationships are used to
sharing patience they develop a
perception of how the other person's
going to be able to handle the
information that might be perceived as a
criticism and so knowing that that other
person's receptive to that allows the
communication to happen if you don't
know that someone's gonna melt into a
puddle because you told them that you
changed their diagnosis and it's
perceived as a mistake then there's a
lot of hesitancy about that kind of
communication but when we put a group of
hospitalists in the common team room and
they're working and handing off lists
and they always come together in a room
much smaller than this but a place where
there are six or seven computer
terminals they're always turning over
and saying hey whatever happened to they
establish a way of communicating that's
embedded in the physical proximity the
face-to-face conversation the then made
it a lot easier to pick the phone up and
say can I give you some feedback about
the patient I picked up from you
yesterday or not even using the term
feedback and saying it's my job to
follow up with you so we're looking at
that they removed pockets in our data we
want to try to characterize in a very
preliminary way what are the factors
that allow for that kind of
communication in contrast with the
situations with
was the majority of people who said I
didn't do anything with the information
I didn't know how and I will tell you
just one other finding it seems to be
tribally related so residents feel like
they can talk to other internal medicine
residents but they can't talk to
residents from other specialties it goes
and it goes across specialty boundaries
even within internal medicine
so cases that came out of the ICU they
changed the diagnosis and I said well
what you do with that information
oh nothing and it's not my
responsibility to tell the ICU Doc's
that they missed a case of influenza and
I was like biting my tongue that's a
reason as a researcher interviewer hey
let's worry about that
why would it not be your responsibility
is sort of what I wanted to go which was
not the purpose of the interview it
we've got to get over ourselves in order
to improve the quality of care over
these discontinuities so I think that
your question is right at the heart of
the third analysis which I'm involved in
right
yes
the change in diagnosis Kevin thanks for
that question I'll repeat it since you
didn't have the microphone that have
there been efforts within the EHR to
allow for notification of the prior
responsible clinicians about a change
diagnosis it's an easy solution if I'm
curious I can wouldn't it be great if I
could just say notify me and let the
next Note pop into my in basket and then
I can look I don't have to create my own
list if I want to know
it'll be fraught with the same issues
the clinicians have which is suddenly I
have this I want to know everything and
then really I don't want to know
everything because I can't actually
possibly look through everything that
I'm curious about so learning how to
pick and choose and decide what's the
most meaning meaningful follow-up
learning for me as a clinician is
another interesting area of follow-up
but I do think there are electronic
health record programming I dare say
that solutions that would allow me to
pick and be asked to be notified about
certain things but to my knowledge none
of that none of my participants talked
about that and yes so I'm not a current
medical student but I did recently
graduate from the program from out of
state so I guess at that institution
that guess as policy was somewhat
similar to what we were describing here
in that there was I don't think anybody
explicitly told us but the rules were
for following up but as long as you have
login access to that particular EHR that
your patient was in you can look up
their information and so I did a
rotation in radiology which required us
to to present a case for the class and
the the problem I felt like I was
running into was that I was never
assigned to any clinical locations
during that rotation in which I was
regularly accessing the computer in the
EHR so when it came time for me to get
those records
for my presentation I felt like I was
sneaking around the hospital trying to
find an open computer it even though I
knew we it was educational requirement
and I wasn't gonna get in trouble for it
but that was other kind of feeling I had
when I was in the process of doing it I
guess my question is is the general
consensus in the medical education
community that med students should have
restricted access there is no consensus
about whether medical students should
have restricted access the very few
publications in the literature are
advocates of restriction because they
don't think that if the students merrily
can be responsible and advocates for
access for learning purposes and getting
over ourselves and thinking that you are
not capable of carrying out the
professional responsibilities as
physicians to be especially from your
clinical work forward but there's no
consensus yet so that's another area of
research that we're pursuing is to try
to understand how different systems work
I very much appreciate your story a
feeling like you needed to sneak around
to do that that tells me something is
going on in the hidden curriculum
because we don't have explicit policies
you're left saying well if I just watch
my role models they're looking and I'm
being encouraged to follow up but I'm
also being trained in the importance of
protecting patients personal health
information so where do I where does
this activity fall and nobody's talking
about it so it leaves me a little
anxious and at least me very anxious
especially if I don't have a home where
people are expecting me to be logging
into my patient charts because I'm on a
clinical rotation and so I'm worrying
big brothers well I can guarantee you
that the big brother is watching right
we have the ability with our electronic
health record systems is to fingerprint
every single access to everything
the question then becomes when is it a
break the glass phenomenon which is what
we call it here when it's a breach and
when does it start approaching a breach
and when should we allow it to happen
and your story makes me even more
excited about trying to clarify that the
whole quagmire so that you don't have to
sneak around to do things that are part
of your educational requirements right I
appreciate your story
another question inspired by the
comments from before so I was curious
were there any thoughts expressed if
they might miss out on educational
opportunities in the patients that they
worried about I was like sure but lovely
question I had a couple of participants
actually say first of all again I went
in with a constructivist grounded Theory
approach not knowing what I was going to
find and as we started discovering that
curiosity was the cornerstone of
figuring out the theory of motivation
that fit with our data and not being
curious enough was a threshold concept I
started asking explicitly what kinds of
patients do you not put on your list and
several stories came out where
clinicians would say well let me
describe that to you and then laugh and
say but I have to presume that I was
actually certain here in order to be
able to say I'm not going to learn
anything and we all can be fooled and
then I would hear about a couple of
stories one story for example was a
patient that clearly had a prototypical
problem the problem was addressed there
really was no curiosity and then this
poor resident got a call from a
colleague saying I just admitted your
patients to the surgery service for the
cholecystectomy right a misdiagnosis so
this person said obviously I made the
bad choice so you could argue on the
basis of those anecdotal stories that we
ought to provide follow-up information
on everything but I'm convinced that
that would swamp us in a different kind
of way when our brains are required to
look
a lot of information we have lots of
evidence that we just dismissed that
right when we have too many clinical
alerts in the electronic health record
as a clinician I just click them out to
get them out of my way it's not what I
want to be looking at right now I need
to do this and then I can't say well
bring those back when I'm ready to look
at this so I we have to be educators and
understand education and motivation and
cognition in order to create a useful
electronic health record for safety and
work and if we say we're going to feed
everything back to you and then you can
learn everything I think that's probably
going to be a mistake in the same way
that over time we can sample take
samples of things that we can learn so
think about it more as a sampling
problem and make sure that the heuristic
of curiosity drives a lot of that follow
up and then surprised you know change
diagnosis should be fed back if I'm not
curious enough on the front end then I
need to trust my colleague on the back
end to say hey guess what happened so I
think there's lots of ways in which we
can solve that but but creating language
within the computer to say I'm going to
give you everything that you could have
ever possibly wanted is probably just
going to create a different kind of
information I think we're at the the
computer just telling me that we're at
the bottom of the hour and we probably
need to wrap up if this has been a fun
fantastic conversation if any of you are
interested in pursuing some of these
interface questions about information
management and education I'd be happy to
hear from you thank you again for
inviting me to come and talk with you
today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]